hey everyone at Sara thread sterner
sorry ENCOM and in this video I want to
give you some tips on how to count a
respiratory rate so Kelly our
respiratory rate seems like a pretty
simple skill but it can be tricky
especially if you're first starting out
and you're trying to collect all those
other vital signs on top of your
respiratory rate plus some patients it's
easy to count the respiratory rate while
in others it's not first let's quickly
review how to count a respiratory rate
so a normal respiratory rate in an adult
is about 12 to 20 breaths per minute but
not only are we counting that rate we're
looking to see if the breathing is
labored or unlaid an example of labored
breathing would be like this and notice
how the patient's chest we can really
see it moving up and down they're using
their mouth to breathe in and breathe
out also we're looking at if the
breathing is irregular or regular so
irregular breathing would be patients
taking a breath here and there it's not
on this consistent rate they may like
take a breath in and out in and out and
then there's a pause and then they'll
breathe again here and there a regular
rate would be there's a consistent
rhythm to that breathing now if the rate
is regular you'll want to count for 30
seconds and multiply by two however if
the rate is irregular you'll want to
count for one complete minute so when
you go to count the respiratory rate you
want to make sure that you were doing it
manually rather than going by the number
that's on the monitor because as a nurse
I have found that that number that that
monitor gives you is usually not the
rate that your patient is breathing so
always double check that now whatever
you do go to count the respiratory rate
you want to make sure that the patient
isn't really aware at that time that
you're counting the respiratory rate
because they will alter the way that
they're breathing it's just like if I
told you I'm going to count how many
times you blink you're going to alter
how much you are blinking you will
change it so whenever you do this skill
you want to combine it with checking the
pulse rate so you'll fill on the side
the radial side the pulse rate count
that like you normally would but then
you're going to keep your finger on that
side
and count the respiratory rate but the
patient thinks that you're counting
their pulse rate still and what you're
looking for is the rise and the fall of
the chest one rise and one fall of the
chest equals one breath but this is
where the tricky part comes into play
because it's like how do I determine
what's a rise and what's a fall of the
chest so I can count one breath and here
are some tips to help you do that now
with these tips you're going to find in
practice that some of these tips work
great on some patients while others you
may have to change it up a bit because
every patient is built differently
they're gonna be wearing different
clothes like some patients are wearing
downs I may not even have a gown on and
some may be wearing their regular street
clothes and a lot of patients they have
different disease processes going on so
one thing I like to do if I know this
patient it's gonna be hard to count
their respiratory rate I'm gonna get
down at the level of their chest like
their shoulder and chest area and their
abdominal level because I'm looking at
that rise and that fall of that chest
I'm getting down here looking at that
while I'm checking that pulse rate so I
start out in that position and some
patients it's really easy to tell
depending on how they breathe like the
shoulder area will move up and down the
chest area will move back and forth or
the abdominal area will go up and down
now if your patient has like a severe
disease process where the respiratory
system is being affected like with
congestive heart failure a lot of fluid
volume overload they have trouble
breathing so they're going to use these
abdominal muscles to help pull in and
out that air you can actually just see
that I've been going in and out so
that's really helpful whenever you're
trying to figure out the rate another
tip you could do but I would use this
with discretion depending on your
patient and how they are would be
whenever you go to feel that pulse rate
you can lightly put your hand on their
back on their chest or whatever so you
can feel the rise and the fall of the
chest but with some patients like if
they're agitated confused or they're
just someone who
he doesn't want you in their personal
space you wouldn't want to use this but
with some patience you can and my last
tip would be to group it with your
physical assessment so whenever you're
going to assess the chest you're gonna
listen to heart sounds and lung sounds
what you want to do is tell the patient
I'm gonna listen to your heart sounds
for one full minute
so while you're there listening to both
heart sounds and then lung sounds
they're not gonna think that something's
wrong so you're going to take your
stethoscope and first you can listen to
their breath sounds and count that rate
it's best to try to pick an area that
you want to count that rate where
there's no a lot of adipose tissue
because I can really muffle those breath
sounds so generally at that second to
fourth intercostal space anteriorly
about mid clavicular that could be a
great place to count those breath sounds
but again it really depends on how your
patient is built then after you count
that rate then you can proceed and
listen to their heart sounds okay so
that wraps up this video on some tips
for counting the respiratory rate and be
sure to check out my other videos such
as a head-to-toe assessment how to
assess heart and lung sounds along with
audio clips of abnormal lung sounds